pop fields died just a few days ago
after catching coronavirus in a care
home he was 80 years old the home didn't
have any tests and so had no way of
telling who had the disease and who
didn't if one person care providers are
now urging the government to roll out
regular and widespread testing for staff
residents and new intakes from hospitals
because without them they say they're
working in the dark and so what would
you want the health secretary to do from
today presumably from tomorrow yes we
need to test
I cannot reinforce that enough from from
not only the staff that employed in my
care homes but across the UK that are
all working in care and in any frontline
capacity that I providing care to what
we are passing is you know what you know
people are in the vulnerable category
this weekend Sky News spent the day in a
care home where more than half of the
residents have coronavirus and today the
health secretary and the medical
director of public health England
admitted more needs to be done to help
struggling Care Homes and I witnessed
flimsy PPE overstretched at a lot of
illness and unfortunately some death of
some of the residents the care sector is
watching this right now and is desperate
for you to tell them that they will get
regular tests so they can end this
lottery can you give that guarantee to
them yes I can that is coming as a
country during this crisis is
recognizing that our care staff are on
the front line just as much as our NHS
staff are and making sure that we expand
that testing capability both to staff
and to residents are you satisfied that
care homes have enough support we're
very aware through our local health
protection teams and our connections
with our local directors of Public
Health and through the local resilience
for about the care homes we profile them
now in a way that perhaps was never done
before and this is very valuable for us
going forward as a country that we have
a truly integrated approach
to care at the moment deaths from koban
19 and nursing homes are not counted in
the daily figures it's feared that more
than a thousand may have died and have
gone uncounted as the government says
hospitals seem to be holding up in this
crisis their biggest support network
social care might be on the verge of
collapse Nick Martin Sky News